We've defined the notion of a
projection onto a subspace,
but I haven't shown you yet that
it's definitely a linear
transformation.
Nor have I shown you that if
you know a basis for a
subspace, how do you actually
find a projection onto it?
So let's see if we can make
any progress on that here.
So let's say I have
some subspace.
Let's say v is a
subspace of Rn.
And let's say I've got some
basis vectors for v.
So let's say these are my basis
vectors, basis vector 1,
2, and I have k of them.
I don't know what v's
dimension is, but
let's say it's k.
It's got k basis vectors,
so it is a basis for v.
And that means that any vector--
that's not v vector,
that's v subspace-- now that
means that any vector-- let me
call some vector, I don't know,
let's say, any vector a
that is a member of my subspace
can be represented.
That means that a can be
represented as a linear
combination of these guys.
So I'll make my linear
combination.
Let's say it is, I don't know,
y1 times b1, plus y2 times b2,
all the way to plus
yk times bk.
That's what the definition
of a basis is.
The span of these guys is your
subspace v, so any member of v
can be represented as a linear
combination of my basis vectors.
Now, if I were to construct a
matrix-- let's make it an n by
k matrix-- whose columns are
essentially the basis vectors
of my subspace.
So A looks like this,
the first column is
my first basis vector.
My second column is my second
basis vector, and I go all the
way to my k column, and I have
k columns, is going to be my
k'th basis vector.
If I'm going to have my k'th
basis vector-- let me make the
closing bracket the same color
as my opening bracket, just
like that-- it's going to have
n rows, because each of these
basis vectors are
members of Rn.
Remember, v is a subspace of Rn,
so each of these guys are
going to have n terms.
So this matrix is
going to have n rows.
Now, saying that any member
of the subspace v can be
represented as a linear
combination of these basis
vectors, is equivalent to saying
that any member, that
a, that any member a of our
subspace v can be represented
as the product of our matrix A,
times some vector y, where
[INAUDIBLE]
was equal to a, for some y,
that is a member of Rk.
Now why is this statement and
that statement equivalent?
Well you can imagine, if you
were to just multiply this
times some vector y in Rk, so
it's y1, y2, all the way down
to yk, this is going to be equal
to y1 times v1, plus y2,
times b2, all the way to plus yk
times bk, which is the same
thing as this.
So you can always pick the
right linear combination.
You can always pick the right
member, yk, so that you get
the right linear combination of
your basis vectors to get
any member of your subspace v.
So any member of my subspace,
right there, can be
represented as the product
of the matrix A with
some vector in Rk.
Now we don't know much about
this vector here in Rk.
Now, the projection-- let's
say that x is just some
arbitrary member of Rn-- the
projection of x onto our
subspace v, that is by
definition going to be a
member of your subspace.
Or another way of saying it is
that this guy, the projection
onto v of x is going to be equal
to my matrix A, is going
to be equal to-- I'll do it in
blue-- is going to be equal to
A times some vector y, or
some vector y in Rk.
If we knew what that vector y
was, if we could always find
it, then we would have a
formula, so to speak, for
figuring out the projection
of x onto v.
But we don't have that yet.
All I've said is, any member of
v can be represented as a
product of our matrix A, which
has the basis for v as
columns, and some
member of Rk.
That just comes out of the fact
that these guys span v,
that any member of
v is a linear
combination of those guys.
We know that the projection of
x onto v is a member of our
subspace v, it has to
be inside of v.
So it can also be represented
this way.
Now what was our definition
of our projection?
Our definition of our
projection, we say--
Well, let me write
it this way.
We know that x can be
represented as the sum of the
projection onto v of x, plus
some member of v complement.
Or maybe I could even write,
plus the projection onto the
orthogonal complement of v.
You could write this way.
I could have also written this
as w, where w is a member of v
complement.
Actually, let me write
it that way.
That might make it simpler.
I don't want to get too many
projections here-- plus w,
where w is a unique member
of the orthogonal
complement of v.
Or you could say it this way,
if you subtract a projection
of x onto v from both sides, you
get x minus the projection
of x onto v, is equal to w.
Or another way to say it is that
this guy right here is
going to be a member of the
orthogonal complement of v,
right, because this is
the same thing as w.
Now what's the orthogonal
complement of v?
We go back to this
matrix here.
I have these basis vectors.
Right here is the columns.
So the column space of A is
going to be equal to v, right?
The column space of
A is just the span
of these basis vectors.
And by definition, that is
going to be equal to my
subspace v.
Now what is the orthogonal
complement of v?
The orthogonal complement of v
is going to be the orthogonal
complement of my column space.
And what's the orthogonal
complement of a column space?
That's equal to the null space
of A transpose, or you could
also call that the left
null space of A.
But we've seen that many,
many, videos ago.
So we could say that x minus the
projection of x onto v as
a member of-- let me write
it this way-- x minus the
projection onto v of x is a
member of the orthogonal
complement of my column space
of my matrix, which is equal
to the null space
of A transpose.
That's the orthogonal
complement of v.
This is the same thing as the
orthogonal complement of v.
But what does this mean?
What does this mean
right here?
This means that if I take A
transpose, and I multiply it
times this vector, because it's
a member of A transpose's
null space.
So if I multiply it times that
vector right there-- so,
projection of x onto v-- then
I'm going to get 0.
I'm going to get the 0 vector.
That's the definition
of a null space.
So let's write this out
a little bit more.
Let's see if we can
algebraically
manipulate it a bit.
So if we distribute this matrix
vector product, we get
A transpose times the vector
x, minus A transpose, times
the projection-- actually let
me write this this way.
Instead of keep writing the
projection onto v of x, what
did we say earlier
in this video?
We said the projection of v onto
x can be represented as
the matrix product of
the matrix A, times
some vector y in Rk.
That's where we started
off the video.
So let me write it that way,
because that's what going to
simplify our work
a little bit.
So I'm going to distribute
the A transpose, A
transpose times x.
And then A transpose, minus A
transpose, times this thing.
This thing I can write as A
times some vector y, and this
is just a byproduct of the
notion that the projection is
a member of our subspace.
Because it's a member of our
subspace, it's going to be
some linear combination of
the column vectors of A.
We saw that up here, so it can
be represented in this way.
So instead of projection onto
v of x, I can just write Ay.
This thing and this thing are
equivalent, because this thing
is a member of v.
And then all of that is going
to be equal to 0.
And then if we add this to both
sides of this equation,
we get that A transpose x is
equal to A transpose A of y.
Now this is interesting.
Remember where we started
off here.
We said that the projection onto
v of x is equal to Ay for
some y that is a member of Rk.
If we knew what that y was, if
we could always solve for that
y, then the projection of
x would be well defined.
And we could always just
figure it out.
Now can we solve for y here?
Well, we'll be able to solve
for y if we can take the
inverse of that matrix.
If this major is always
invertible, then we're always
going to be able to
solve for y here.
Because we just take the inverse
of this matrix and
multiply it times the
left side of both
sides in this equation.
Now if you remember, three
videos ago, I think it was
three videos ago, I showed you
that if I have a matrix A
whose columns are linearly
independent, then A transpose
A is always invertible.
The whole reason why I did that
video was for this moment
right here.
Now, what about our matrix A?
Well, our matrix A has column
vectors that form the basis
for a subspace.
By definition, basis vectors
are linearly independent.
So our matrix A has columns that
And if you watched that video,
and if you believe what I told
you, then you'll know that A
transpose A, in our case, is
going to be invertible.
It has to be inveritible.
So let's take the inverse
of it and multiply
it times both sides.
If we take A transpose A
inverse-- we know that this
exists, because A has linearly
independent columns-- and
multiply it times this side
right here, A transpose x.
And then on this side we get--
well, we're going to do the
same thing-- A transpose A
inverse, times this thing
right here, A transpose Ay.
These two things when you
multiply them, when you
multiply the inverse of a
matrix, times the matrix,
you're just going to get
the identity matrix.
So that's just going to be equal
to the identity matrix.
And the identity matrix times y
is just going to be y, so we
get-- and this is a vector--
so if I flip them around, I
get that y is equal to this
expression right here.
A transpose A inverse, which'll
always exist, times A
transpose, times x.
Now we said the projection of x
onto v is going to be equal
to A times y, for some y.
Well we just solved for the y
using our definition of a
projection.
We just were able
to solve for y.
So now, we can define our
projection of x onto v as a
matrix vector product.
So we can write the projection
onto v of our vector x is
equal to A, times y, and
y is just equal to
that thing right there.
So A times A transpose A
inverse-- which always exists
because A has linearly
independent columns-- times A
transpose, times x.
And this thing right here, this
long convoluted thing,
that's just some matrix, some
matrix which always exists for
any subspace that
has some basis.
So we've just been able to
express the projection of x
onto a subspace as a matrix
vector product.
So anything that can be any
matrix vector product
transformation is a linear
transformation.
And not only did we show that
it's a linear transformation,
we showed that, look, if you can
give me the basis for v,
I'm going to make those column
vectors equal to the column of
some matrix A.
And then if I take matrix A, if
I take its transpose, if I
take A transpose times A, and
invert it, and if I multiply
them all out in this way,
I'm going to get the
transformation matrix
for the projection.
Now this might seem really
complicated, and it is hard to
do by hand for many, many
projections, but this is super
useful if you're going to do
some three-dimensional
graphical programming.
Let's say you have some
three-dimensional object, and
you want to know what it looks
like from the point of view of
some observer.
So let's say you have
Some observer's point of view
is essentially going to be
some subspace.
You want to see what the
projection of this cube onto
the subspace, how would it
look to the person who's
essentially on to this flat
screen right there.
How would that cube look from
this point of view?
Well if you know the basis for
this subspace, you can just
apply this transformation.
You can make a matrix whose
columns are these basis
vectors for this observer's
point of view.
And then you can apply this to
every vector in this cube in
R3, and you'll know exactly how
this cube should look from
this person's point of view.
So this is actually a
super useful result.